and then I thought I'd I thought I'd
discovered something new at the spa oh
and I want people to hear me if you're a
guy and you live in LA you really need
to go to this Korean spa with me and I'm
inviting people don't invite everyone
man I don't know I invite two people
number one dudes you know you would you
will see my dick
this sounds like a grinder add want to
see dudes and it's Bob it's an all-male
spa so it's gotta be only dude it's not
a sexual thing but proceed with caution
when you invite all of Los Angeles to
and go into many people in LA that are
guys that are willing to go to the spa
with me live in LA all of West Hollywood
I guarantee you if you give them the
time and place at least 150 men will
show up at a smoker I said to [ __ ] we
have to decide my side who the two are
anyway and it's open 24 hours I go at
like really weird hours like midnight
1:00 2:00 in the morning and I want to
tiger belly fans to just go to the spot
with me you're gonna see my penis you're
gonna see my ritual but I figured out a
way new way to clean myself is how you
usually do it but now but also explains
the new way my brother and I will go and
okay so you go and there's pool tables
in the front of this Inn in the lobby of
this place cool or ping-pong no there's
pull tables King Kong's upstairs and
there's always like shady [ __ ] Korean
characters a there's a guy that dresses
full camo and it's Bob but yeah ignore
Ian a Korean guy Oh fool but not even
like Vietnam camo Desert Storm but I
better turn can't like not help you at
all right here and there's another guy
he hangs out with is this fatter man
where he wears a wife-beater suspenders
but the Mork & Mindy kind the Mork &
Mindy suspenders
right he's got a mustache aviator
glasses at night yeah right he wears one
of those you ever see on poltergeist -
mm-hmm the evil guy in that yeah what
were they
like an Amish black hat pretty much it's
like a um it's it's it's a it's a
[ __ ] hat a black [ __ ] hat man
[ __ ] inside hurry in the Korean dude
this is why and he has a wad of cash and
he's always like throwing it on tables
for some reason but I don't really try
to analyze it because I feel like if I
lock eyes with him then I'm gonna be in
for some [ __ ] like talk to me okay well
yo you are and then I had to be able
mule drugged me or something yeah for it
so I look at him before a split second
and I'll just walk by so you don't
interact with anyone there what about
the [ __ ] about gonna say what's up
nicest fenders so then I go in and my
brother if my brother's there we
immediately take a [ __ ] okay we go to I
go to the big stall he goes little one
and we let power move by Bobby [ __ ] at
the same time and we also giggle we just
gotta go far and I'll go you know giggle
it's so much fun we'll just giggle like
kids you know I mean and then we get
naked you put your clothes in the locker
you can walk into this spa and it
reminds you of like the 70s and there
they just nothing's modern it's that
that the tiles that the color scheme is
like this Soviet core green right Soviet
green yeah you know everyone knows a
Soviet green yeah you know like an
alien's [ __ ]
I thought on the roswall we used to go
to yeah
and then here's what I do now also the
steam room is illegal what do you mean
oh I've been in that it's the heat did
it they don't sure they don't turn it
off for 24 hours a day every day for the
net for all year oh when you walk in
there it's like the surface of the Sun
it's so [ __ ] hot
you like die there you literally I've
seen guys walk in and walk out someone
did die they're less oh yeah no like a
couple of months ago no you said - - no
because I just saw Tanaka oh yeah yeah
yeah so Alex Tanaka
if you guys don't know who he is if you
guys ever seen the movie Rushmore
anybody else seen the movie yes the
Chinese girl that's in there from old
school - yeah she plays um Rushmore's
girlfriend in it she's also the girl
from old school yeah rats him out at the
very end yeah that's her brother and her
brother was the executive producer of
animal practice the NBC sitcom I was on
there's a documentary crew in here we
gotta tell people and I'm doing it
there's a documentary crew from England
and I'm giving them little Winky wings
okay hey animal practice so I did some
ADR for this guy Alex Tanaka and he goes
because I introduced him to the spa you
go oh man you know what happened the
other day I go what I was in the steam
room and I look over and guy was dead
next to me yeah and he goes yeah and
then I just sat there and the ambulance
came they pulled him out and they just
didn't close the place you stayed in the
steam room yeah so that's what so this
is my new theory though I'm the method
okay I did it once last week and I
walked in and I take a shower and I
laughter my body with soap okay
like to the point where I look like a
snowman
like a lather to the point where it's
like I look like I'm wearing like a
spacesuit super bubbly like yeah it's a
it's an its clothing like a Michelin Man
yeah yeah right there you go thank you
and I walk sit into that steam room and
for some reason in my mind and I don't
think this is healthy but I feel like
the pores open in my skin and that soap
goes into my skin okay okay right and I
start scratching my body with the soap
right and if I look at my nails listen
yeah just make a point do you know your
skin is watertight right
there's pores in it though I know he's
trained Oh tell me about that skin it's
it's watertight so it's only permeable
one direction like you think if your
skin if your door is actually open
things can be susceptible to so many
diseases Wow so you're just cracking
yourself really hard so you're saying is
unless you have an open wound the pores
are like my butthole only one thing goes
on one way one directional unlike
Georgia's butthole multiple things
everywhere everywhere everything the
largest organ and protect the organ
gelati Oh
so when pores opens what comes out but
not any but you kid doesn't go in I
cannot go in it shouldn't go and imagine
if water could just just freely go in
and out of your skin it doesn't work
then what are other people's reactions
when you walk into the steamer Monday
hey that yeah yeah but that's scary
because at least for a woman when you
soap your vagina yeah and even if a
little bit of soap goes in your your
whole yeah oh it burns when you actually
finally pee yeah it burned it's
excruciating does does it feel the same
for men when the soap goes into the dick
hole Mike dick has no feeling like it
died 12 years ago you learn as a kid
don't jerk off with Head & Shoulders
that really hurts once you pee
afterwards whoa don't jerk off you know
you don't jerk off with what is that
tiger balm do that oh yeah yeah that
[ __ ] burns a break
I do I'm okay I'm gonna tell you or
something right now and I want to do
this as a contest everyone jerk off with
I swear to god how about this dude
Gilbert I'll give you I'm not even
[ __ ] kidding you dude
three hundred and cash if we could just
put Tiger Balm over your dick and see
how long you can last without taking a
shower I mean you know I'll do it but I
mean we got a I'll be out update with
that ABC money I mean yeah how much
money five hundred bucks like a thousand
a grand a grand just make sure you cover
it I know you can't do believe you can
die first of all let's do yeah we'll get
let's play with Tiger Bombers to people
not Asian it's uh what's that other
stuff that American version of that I
don't know it like I see how it just a
homeopath like yeah yeah Mike will not
have a fix like a like a Vic's right
methanol yeah yeah I think it's a cat
there has to be like camphor that
burning yeah anyway burns I also thought
about it some more the skin does absorb
to a certain extent like it does absorb
lotion and things like that so maybe the
soap does steep into it sounds so stupid
and his theory was correct no I'm just
saying it doesn't steep into like your
bloodstream to go to my bloodstream what
I want is it to get into my skin lotion
permeable one-way water thing no your
skin does absorb some which is not as
deep as you need it to okay so anyway I
knew so cuz I was in there and so I
would scratch my body with the soap on
it and it felt like you know I was
getting softer no I was getting like
some great dirt Oh like dirt was coming
we call it in Korean bungee yeah it's
mangy yeah Korean is mangy it's when you
rub your skin and then you get that
black not like black but dirt oh my dad
used to clean me like that when I was a
kid yeah black mangy we should call it
lungi
so I was it was doing that but then the
then I did it three days after that and
I [ __ ] up it was the most painful
thing I'm gonna try my face in my head
too right so I now I'm fully covered
I just look like a [ __ ] like like an
elephant jerked off on my [ __ ] face
that's a lot of good right hey guys
that's a lot of car yeah yeah and I walk
in there
it had my eyes closed I walked in there
I just got down and I opened my eye for
just a second and this soap just went
into my eyes and I was blinded
it hurts so [ __ ] bad ah like that
right I'm in the steam room 2:00 in the
morning
Oh like this right but I'm like I'm not
gonna go out and wash myself because I'm
in here already but it was so painful
I'm not gonna go it was so painful so it
does work my theory oh man gmod
that
[Music]